maybe I've just got here in Vegas what's
more fun than 50 bartenders in Vegas
there's just this awesome view of Las
Vegas strip literally competing against
the best bartenders in this country once
I got behind the bar I was like once it
was under the tent it's all nerves then
the judges came over and they sat right
in front of me and this is actually
about to happen down your luck when I
pulled everything out of my bag I pulled
my first glass out and I was polishing
it and I'm like looking for any dust or
marks on it and I see just a big crack
that's not good I started asking around
no one had double rocks glasses terms of
rocks glasses
the only things like so right after they
called our names we all piled into the
elevator with our trays and that's about
the time when the nerves started to
really hit me in the stomach got really
nervous I got really nervous and that's
my news like all right this is it it's
time the day I found out I was going to
Vegas I sent out a text message to my
mom my dad and my brother just saying
hey I won this awesome thing I'm going
to Vegas to compete
and then a little while later I heard
back from my mom and she just said I
will always love you but I can't be
proud of you for this and it felt like
someone punched me in the stomach I just
kept reading it over and over again like
wow wow she sees bartending in the same
light as like being a stripper and that
I'm contributing to the downfall of
society I create memories and
experiences for people and people leave
there and post my name all over Yelp
like Carly made me an awesome drink last
night at whistlers like it's like what I
do is awesome if I win I want to be able
for her to be the first person that I
call and like hear like celebrating in
the background
but it won't be like that's not gonna be
what happened I hope that if I win and
that she'll come around and and that she
will be really proud of me
are you ready to go I'm ready I've been
ready to do this competition for weeks
now I've been practicing my drink and it
was right there I mean I was seconds
away it was just right there in front of
me I was ready to go okay
starting with a little lemon juice here
bouncing and half of Bombay time for a
little shake my friends were super
pumped you know they're like you got
this that's the face of GQ they're I
think they're all a little more
confident than I am the final step to my
drink was my ice cube picked up the ice
cube and everybody's face in the crowd
changed most judges were like well thank
you first step always they smell the
drink they want to get the aroma off the
drink when you smell my drink you get
that sake cinnamon flavor just the
perfect balance for a gin cocktail it's
good really good
what on Carly awesome
I feel good I mean that was the best
drink I could have put out to the judges
today and it was awesome it tasted good
I tasted it after and I was like if I
drink that I think it's a simple drink
but presentation wise and the whole
package
it's enough to give me the top two so
before the competition started I saw
that there is glasses holding candles on
the tables I ended up polishing those in
using the a candle holders my glassware
if it wasn't for those I don't really
know what I would have done how's it got
chat very well it's my first time in
Vegas so it's like you really got to
hold back so am i late for my friends
came out today she's been getting like
super wasted every day and like going
wild so I'm just like I'm so glad you
guys are having fun but I'm gonna go to
bed I'm much more comfortable what I'm
talking so it kind of helped me relax a
little bit so the card says I'm gonna
have for you guys today
it's named after the neighborhood I live
in indicia Bloomingdale what you have is
the base that's very tart and citrusy so
as you'll taste the cocktail itself is
its aggressive it's a very aggressive
cocktail I interacted with the judges
quite a bit and we kind of hit it off I
feel like we connected on some stuff
they kind of took a very professional
manner so I don't think they reacted in
an enormous ly positive way then this is
the galangal infusion very quick have
you ever used to galangal before yeah
obviously during this competition
everyone's like so what ingredients are
you using and tell them Galan love it
like hell is going on go a little absent
to finish it off
fresh breath is going down fine
alright gentlemen the Bloomingdale the
glass worked very well if you didn't
know that it was a candle holder you
probably would just assume it was a
glass so I doubt the judges realized
anything was amiss might just be the
most imaginative bartender to use a
candle holder for a glass could have
gone a little better I was like you know
a little shaky but now we go have a
drink and wait until the top ten are
announced I just feel like a winner
already congratulations buddy
what was going through my head was
Vietnam like just just rock it with a
guy behind the bar and once it was under
the tent it's all nerves like you know
adrenaline is kicking in and you do what
you do or you step off when I was right
behind the bar I was totally my stomach
kind of leaped up into my throat for a
second the crowd kind of went live and
nuts and the judges went wide-eyed
absolutely no fish to your dream do it
right go go go go go go go like push it
out get it over with
it's looking intimidating now the
anticipation of waiting for the results
is starting to build this is why I came
here what your name to be announced I
don't know what's gonna happen
you